J'ai été obligé de prendre ces sacs dans mes
bagages le public était obsédé par
l'histoire il y avait une fascination autour
de son chignon
c'est très jeune et je
veux dire
[Musique]
quand il a été diffusé sur diverses chaînes d'information
cette séquence montrait deux jeunes
femmes qui avaient l'air absolument  terrifiés par
ce qu'ils s'étaient mis dans
quel est ton nom Michaela
était ta nationalité irlandaise
est
[Musique]
tu sais contenir de la drogue est [
Musique] [
Musique]
Michaela était comme n'importe quelle autre jeune
femme d'Irlande du Nord, elle venait
d'un milieu rural, elle  voulait être
mannequin, je sais qu'elle avait fait du travail
dansant dans des clubs et des choses comme ça,
puis elle a pris la décision, comme
beaucoup de jeunes femmes et hommes feraient à
ce stade de leur vie, d'aller en
Espagne et de travailler et  faire la fête et s'amuser Le
raid de Melissa venait d'un très bon
milieu, elle avait une bonne famille comme
Michaela, elle allait en Espagne pour
s'amuser à la fois Melissa et Michaela, vous
ne croiriez jamais dans un million d'années
qu'elles se retourneraient contre des
trafiquants de drogue internationaux
ont été arrêtés  à l'aéroport de Lima, nous
avions travaillé sur une histoire impliquant
Michaela McCallum et le fait qu'elle
avait disparu et que les
gens d'Ibiza s'inquiétaient pour elle, sa famille
faisait place aux médias, ils ont été
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux en essayant de
la retrouver et  aussi des célébrités et
des stars du sport aidaient dans cette recherche pour la
retrouver
[Musique]
J'ai été forcé de prendre ces sacs dans mes
bagages, elle a en fait été kidnappée
sous la menace d'une arme
et forcée par un fil,
pas l'équipe de son arrestation, les gens ici collectaient
des fonds pour des vêtements  pour Nécessités
pour que la nourriture soit centrée dans la prison
étrangère
[Musique]
et apparemment Jake était le lien avec le
monde souterrain de la drogue qui
a amené Michaela et Melissa Red à
transporter ces drogues,
le public a commencé à se rendre compte que
Michaela et Melissa étaient plus impliquées
dans ce  ce qu'ils voulaient que les gens
croient et le soutien du public
en Irlande du Nord a en quelque sorte
disparu pour Michaela McCollum
est que
le public était obsédé par l'histoire
il y avait une fascination autour de son chignon
ouais les liens Pareto c'était très
étrange je veux dire nous avions même  les enfants se sont
déguisés pour Halloween
quelques mois après leur
arrestation, c'était tout simplement fou
[Musique]
Je n'y suis pas allé Je n'ai rien à
manger aujourd'hui
Je devais
vous connaître l'expérience de mon temps dans un
état horrible présent vous savez
dormir dans le sol et j'ai perdu
beaucoup d'années de ma vie
euh vous savez à cause de la drogue j'étais une
période vraiment très difficile pour ma famille
et moi
je  nous sommes allés au Pérou nous sommes allés à la
prison et j'ai pu entrer et
lui parler l'intérieur de la prison est
contrôlé par les prisonniers et les
conditions étaient je veux dire les murs étaient
fissurés par les tremblements de terre il y avait
des insectes juste un monde loin de  à quoi
ressemblerait une personne ici au Royaume-Uni
[Musique] c'est l'
une des prisons les plus sûres du Pérou,
c'est aussi l'une des plus
notoires, certains ici l'appellent les produits Hell's
Hacienda,
ils m'ont dit de ne même pas essayer de lutter
contre il n'y a  innocence
étrangère
[Musique]
Spotlight et pour devenir un
trafiquant de drogue international, elle doit être une personne très forte
pour traverser ce qu'elle a
traversé
parce que
[Musique]
J'ai l'impression d'avoir appris beaucoup de choses
de mon temps à  Le Pérou et j'ai l'impression d'avoir
grandi
plus fort tu sais depuis que j'ai été
libéré tu sais et je ne ferais pas
facilement confiance aux gens comme je le faisais tu sais que je
ne suis pas aussi naïf ou immature que je l'étais et
tu sais que je  Je viens d'apprendre à être une
meilleure personne et tu sais être capable de
dire non à des situations avec lesquelles je pourrais me sentir
mal à l'aise
merci